today we're going to talk about why you
should say yes I think it's important to
say yes to opportunities and the reason
why jen and i are even meeting here is
because she said yes i'm in seattle with
microsoft working on a deal and message
jen today yesterday yesterday yesterday
yesterday and said jen i'm in seattle do
you want to meet up cuz she's in
Portland Horton from Seattle it's a
three-hour drive we ever tried yeah we
can't we can't go out too late just you
gotta get riding entrepreneur now so and
you know and and she just said yes and
she came out and i think one you know
lesson is it never hurts to ask I've
learned that more more as an
entrepreneur where if I'm feeling
something then I'll just I'll say it
right because you never know what people
are going to say and sometimes they'll
just say yes you'll say yes yeah in fact
you know in my coaching with Anthony
he's adjusted make youtube videos I was
like like why should a copywriter make
videos they should be writing and I
thought well why not I'll say yes I'll
give it a try and it's been a great
platform for me I love it and it's a
great way to spread my message so
and so glad I said yes then too and we
doing more videos name we're doing when
used together so say yes yeah yeah so
our question for you today is where are
you afraid to say yes to what are you
afraid to say yes to leave it in the
comments below and we'll join in the
discussion thank you guys for watching
this episode of lunch and earn it seem
to believe and we'll see you soon